It's called a BACULUM.
But we'll just call it a penis bone because
of reasons.
Hey friends, Laci Green here.
If you're like me, you probably don't find
yourself thinking about
animal penises too often.
But today, that changes.
In humans, the penis is made up of spongey
cylinders that have lots of blood vessels.
Those blood vessels fill up with blood and
boom, ready for copulation.
This is actually a rarity amongst mammalians
though....MOST mammals have a penis bone instead.
Various primates, rodents, bats, insects,
bears, cats, dogs....
they all have em!
The largest baculum in the animal kingdom
belongs to
the walrus, and
it reaches up to 30 inches long.
Which....doesn't sound too cute if I'm being
honest.
And the award for freakiest penis bone goes
to
the seed beetle, because it.....
looks like a torture device from hell.
In mammals with a baculum, the bone stays
tucked away inside the body until it's sexytime.
Then it's pushed out with the help of abdominal
muscles into a fleshy penis sheath that surrounds
the bone.
It's pret-ty efficient if you think about
it.
Just flex and you're all ready to go.
Kinda makes you wish
you had a penis bone, right?
Pffff.
So jelly.
So why don't humans have one?
Blame it on NATURAL SELECTION yall.
A few years ago, scientists in Switzerland
conducted an experiment with those freaky
seed beetles.
See, the reason their
beetle penis credit Johanna Rönn
penis bone is so spiney is because it helps
to scrub away the sperm from the beetles competitors.
So, the beetle with the spiniest peen can
make more babies.
In the experiment, the beetles were isolated
from any sexual competition - just 1 female
and 1 male.
They observed their monogamous mating and
offspring for 21 generations - all the while
keeping a close eye on those penises.
What they found was that without any competition,
the spines got shorter.
Without as much competition, they didn't need
it anymore!
In other species, the shape and size of the
baculum may help animals have more opportunities
to mate because they can be speedy about it
and they can have many mates in a short period
- like
the lion, who can copulate 250 times in 4
days.
I know right?..........dang.
Some scientists hypothesized that the baculum
may help the male deliver more sperm, and
others think that it could help get the sperm
closer to the egg.
All of these functions translate into more
babies and a better chance of genetic survival.
So in humans....we don't actually know for
sure why we lost our baculum, but there are
a few theories.
One is
monogamy.
Just like those beetles, monogamy makes the
mating game less competitive and so we may
have grown out of the need.
Another similar theory is that we just don't
mate as much or as quickly.
We like to....pull up a chair, have a glass
of wine, get to know each other first...i
mean, we're not ANIMALS...............oh wait.
Alright peeps, there you got it.
Penis bones!
Important knowledge for your brain.
Thanks for joining me, we'll catcha again
soon with more DNews updates.